The upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon,
is based on the George RR Martin's Targaryen
history book Fire & Blood.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In other words it covers events from Aegon's
Conquest to the Dance of the Dragons.
Thats Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Vlood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
When people speak about Aegon's conquest,
people always speak how it's Aegon and his
sister-wives Rhaenyra and Visenya who conquered
and united the Seven Kingdoms,
but they forget to mention their half-brother
born out of wedlock, Orys Baratheon.
Son of Aerion Targaryen, Orys played just
as big role in Aegon's Conquest.
He might not have ridden a dragon (which he
most certainly would have
if there had been a fourth dragon as he was
the blood of a dragon himself)
but he commanded Aegon's armies on the ground.
As Aegon the Conqueror said it himself, Orys
was his shield, his stalwart, his strong right
hand.
Why was Orys a Baratheon and not a Targaryen
you may ask.
Well, Orys and Aegon had the same father,
Aerion Targaryen, but different mothers,
and unlike Aegon's mother, Orys' mother did
not wed their father,
therefore Orys couldn't get a Targaryen surname
as he was born out of wedlock.
How and why did Orys get Baratheon surname
is unknown,
but it's likely that Baratheon surname was
used in Valyria for children born out of wedlock
like Snow, Sand and a few more are used for
children born out of wedlock in Westeros.
Lord Orys Baratheon was the founder of House
Baratheon,
and was half-brother of King Aegon I Targaryen.
That's right, first Baratheon was blood of
the dragon, half Targaryen himself.
Orys was one of Aegon's fiercest commanders,
and was regarded as Aegon's only true friend
and champion of his youth. During the War
of Conquest,
he was a commander in the army of Aegon the
Conqueror.
When Aegon invaded Westeros, he sent Orys
to seize Storm's End,
the ancestral seat of the Storm Kings and
capital of the Stormlands.
Orys defeated the Storm King, Argilac the
Arrogant, and took not only Storm's End,
but also his sigil (the crowned black stag)
and words ("Ours is the Fury"), as well as
his daughter Argella, and his sword, to cement
his rule over the Stormlands.
He became the first Lord Paramount of the
Stormlands.
Orys is also considered the first Hand of
the King, serving Aegon the Conqueror.
Famed for his prowess in battle, his commanding
skills and his strong loyalty to King Aegon
I and House Targaryen, Orys was described
as a fierce warrior, fighting for House Targaryen
during Aegon's Conquest, the First Dornish
War, and the Vulture Hunt.
Being the founder of House Baratheon, Orys
Baratheon is the distant ancestor of King
Robert Baratheon and his brothers, Stannis
and Renly. Orys had black hair and black eyes,
as well as black beard.
In Game of Thrones, if you paid close attention,
you could notice that he has an entry in The
Lineages and Histories of the Great Houses
of the Seven Kingdoms. It reveals Orys's marriage
to Argella,
and that one of his sons died stopping an
assassination attempt
against the son of his half brother Aegon
the Conqeuror, King Aenys Targaryen.
Little is known about his youth, but what
is known is that Orys was Aegon's champion.
When King Argilac Durrandon offered Aegon
his daughter Argella in marriage and some
lands
as her dowry, the Lord of Dragonstone, Aegon
spurned the Storm King's proposal.
Instead, he requested significantly more land
and offered to seal the pact by wedding Orys
to Argilac's daughter.
The Storm King angrily rejected these terms,
for Argilac the Arrogant believed that this
was supposed to be an insult for Orys might
have been Aegon's brother and have Targaryen
blood,
but Orys was a born out of wedlock
and the Storm King viewed such a match would
dishonor his daughter.
Angered at the insult of being offered a man
born out of wedlock instead of a king,
Argilac cut off the hands of Aegon's envoys.
When Aegon's Conquest's had begun, Orys had
command on the ground during the first battle,
defeating Lords Mooton and Darklyn.
Orys led the army while Aegon attacked from
the skies.
After Aegon's coronation at Aegonfort, Orys
was raised to Hand of the King.
Within days of the coronation, Orys and Queen
Rhaenys Targaryen, with her dragon Meraxes,
were then tasked with capturing Storm's End,
taking the greater part of Aegon's host with
them.
While King Argilac gathered his banners,
Lords Fell, Buckler, and Errol ambushed the
advance elements of Orys's host,
until they were forced to retreat when Meraxes
burned the surrounding woods.
Argilac the Arrogant, hearing of the burning
of Harrenhal,
knew his formidable walls would not protect
him from dragonfire.
Argilac rode out with his great host to give
open battle and die with a sword in hand.
Orys was made aware of Argilac's march by
Rhaenys, who provided him with the Storm King's
numbers and dispositions, for she had spotted
the host with her dragon.
Baratheon took up a strong position on the
hills south of Bronzegate,
digging in on the high ground while he awaited
the stormlanders.
Argilac's host was twice the size of Orys's,
and when the battle called the Last Storm
begun,
the stormlanders managed to break through
the Baratheon center,
only to be engulfed by dragonflame. With Meraxes
and Rhaenys turning the battle into chaos,
Orys descended down the hill, where he encountered
the Storm King.
Ordering his own men to stand aside, he gave
Argilac a chance to yield.
Argilac cursed Orys and they fought instead.
Although he took wound, Orys slew Argilac
the Arrogant, ending the reign of the Storm
Kings. The loss of their king made the stormlanders
surrender or flee.
After the battle, Argella Durrandon, the daughter
of Argilac, declared herself the Storm Queen
and continued to hold Storm's End until her
household turned against her
to avoid the same fate of Harrenhal. They
delivered her to Orys, naked and chained.
Orys, however, covered her with his cloak
and treated her chivalrously.
Aegon rewarded Orys with the lands and incomes
of Storm's End and named him Lord Paramount
of the Stormlands. None dared suggest that
he was unworthy of these honors.
Orys took Argella as his wife and to honor
Argliac's valor,
he adopted the stag banner, honors and words
of the Durrandons, "Ours is the Fury", forming
House Baratheon. Orys later joined King Aegon
I in the First Dornish War in 4 AC,
leading an assault on the Boneway with one
thousand picked knights.
His horses struggled up the stony, narrow,
and twisty paths,
while his knights were hit with boulders from
above, the work of defenders the stormlanders
never saw.
Cunning Dornishmen then launched a night raid,
raining arrows, rocks, and spears from above
as the stormlanders crossed a bridge. Bodies
of the invading army blocked the Boneway from
both ends, and when Lord Orys ordered his
men to fall back, a triggered rockfall cut
off their retreat.
With no way forward or back, the stormlanders
were massacred,
save for Orys and a dozen other lords thought
worth the ransom.
However, Orys and his bannermen found themselves
the captives of the Wyl of Wyl
the savage mountain lord called the Widow-lover.
When Aegon eventually agreed to the Dornish
ransom demands, Lord Baratheon and his bannermen
were ransomed in 7 AC
for each man's weight in gold. However, they
were freed only after having their sword hands
chopped off so they would not be able to use
them again against Dorne.
Thereafter Orys became known as Orys One-Hand.
In retaliation for this treachery, King Aegon
descended on the mountain fastnesses of House
Wyl
with his dragon Balerion and burned them to
rubble,
although the Wyls managed to take refuge in
their caves and tunnels beneath the mountains.
After the loss of his hand in the First Dornish
War, Orys became bitter,
turning his attention to Dorne and obsessed
with the idea of revenge.
He resigned his office as Hand and returned
to the stormlands.
While resinging, he said to Aegon ''The King's
Hand should have a hand. I will not have men
speaking of the King's Stump.'' He became
obsessed with vengeance against the Dornish,
especially House Wyl, whose lord had removed
his hand.
When Princess Deria Martell came to King's
Landing to provide peace terms,
Lord Orys argued for sending the princess
back to her father Nymor, the Prince of Dorne,
without a hand, but Aegon made peace with
Dorne instead.
Orys received his opportunity for vengeance
against the Wyls in the Second Dornish War,
during the early reign of Aegon's son, King
Aenys I Targaryen.
In 37 AC, a Dornish outlaw known as the Vulture
King
led a huge army to reave the lands north of
the Red Mountains.
The Vulture King split his host, having one
half led by Lord Walter Wyl.
The Lord of Storm's End, Orys, eager for revenge
against the Dornish,
led his forces from Storm's End one last time
to participate in the Vulture Hunt.
While Wyl's host sat besieging Stonehelm,
Orys's forces crushed the Dornishmen beneath
the walls of the castle.
Lord Walter Wyl, the son of Wyl who chopped
off Orys' hand, was brought to Orys, wounded,
but alive.
''Your father took my hand. I claim yours
as repayment.'' Orys said to him, but he took
far more.
Lord Baratheon chopped off Walter's sword
hand, then his other hand, followed by both
feet,
which he called his "usury" or in other words,
his prolonged revenge with interest at unreasonably
high rates.
On his trip home to Storm's End, legendary
Orys died of the wounds he had taken in the
battle.
Orys died content, according to his son Davos,
smiling that he got his revenge.
Orys Baratheon, blood of the dragon played
a huge role in Aegon's Conquest,
and is one of the most important characters
from this time period.
An honorable man who upholds his loyalty to
his half brother Aegon
and whose prowess in battle was greater even
of that of Aegon himself
which he proved in the war against the last
Storm King,
and whose commanding skills earned Aegon the
Conqueror
quite a few important victories in Westeros.
Can we just take a moment to say that this
Baratheon crown suits Henry Cavill very well.
Huge, strong man with black hair and good
swordmanship, like a true Baratheon.
Perfect choice for Orys Baratheon.
Let me know your thoughts about all of this
in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching and hope to
see you in the next one.
Peace!